all right so let's do the other three
but let's point something out
here um he's pushing he's giving you the
Yang aspect
okay and what we're going to do is
Yin provide the yin aspect to it okay
we're going to do it both internally and
externally remember that
okay uh so for example we're here and so
I'm not going to do it externally but
I'll do it internally
okay and uh so I didn't move back I
didn't make circles or anything I'll do
it
internally and then you can
see that what I'm allowing to happen is
for example he pushes on me I don't y or
try to resist it or externally go
backwards what's going to happen is I
internally yield eventually because he's
press into me I will touch the center so
you touch the
center without any kind of external
manipulation do you understand that so
here we're kind of here only
we're here only but as soon as I release
and he keeps pressing then
eventually I can feel the
center with no movement at
all we're going to do that but we're
going to add an external yield but that
has to happen on the inside okay so for
example last time we did this some of
you had to bend your elbow and that's
because you don't have the internal
yield so all of it has to be achieved
externally okay but when I do that same
thing he's pushing pushing pushing
eventually he'll touch the center I'll
touch the center from where I at then I
can do it here and by the time we get
here we're already in that part you're
touching
him so even in the standard one you're
doing it so here you have your external
yield you
see but I need to get the internal
Center in the timing when I get here
then I already have
that I don't not have it and then try to
push it over do you understand so I do
the part that you guys are
seeing here but you have to understand
by the time I get here I already feel
that I act I'm touching his Center I can
move him in different ways from
here do you understand
okay so you have your standard one here
I touch right I'm in there standard one
and then I
just do the throw as you prescrib okay
on the other one same thing here I've
already touched I'm touching him the
same way touching his Center the same
way so you I'll try to let you so you
can see he could feel it but here he he
doesn't feel me in his Center and then
here he does so there's a couple things
so I'll bring him
up and he can hang out here because his
Center is actually my center now he
doesn't require great balance do you see
he's I'm perfectly balanced and
perfectly controlling him that's what
it's not like he's some Super Hyper
gymnastic person here okay and you can
put him
back or as we were doing boom you can
project out
see so as we move on that's going to
become more important for the other ones
so you're going to have the yield
and by the time you get here you should
already have reached that Center
touching part you can't come around and
go like this and then just push
some this whole
movement
not
here I didn't actually have if you want
to say I had it Center I didn't actually
have it
until about there you see like that but
I'm just pushing
it here we are home same thing have it
have it have it and you can project
it okay try
it it's a feeling okay go
okay do do you see how when you push it
is when you get it
okay so what why that happens is because
I just do it externally you see feel
feel your
body
see so same thing uh well I want you to
do feel the first thing okay so as you
push go ahead push you see your little
knees coming you see that okay so as you
as I'm here and you push me nothing
happens to your base you see that okay
and you push me and I push back at you
go
lock put can you put your knees down yes
do you see you did that so just hold
your base push and I push at
you okay here you go now just release
push as hard as you can as hard as you
can as hard as you can there you go your
knees are floating okay so again go push
as hard as you can and you'll
see okay so now what I have to do is as
you push
I don't not do
that cuz then only here do
I so instead I'm doing that internal
thing you see I'm moving I'm yielding
externally but if you if I stop and I
want to here
look see so I'm going to yield but I I
have it already and I yield and I don't
shut it off I don't go like this I keep
it on as I'm
moving you see so what what you're doing
is
external and then push
I'm trying to do the internal thing here
have it you see look you see I have it
and I move I keep it keep it it went off
a little there I find it again keep it
then I can time
it so that when I get
here you
get
you again your forces coming in to the
ground P you see as opposed to off and
then I push
you
out instead you come in
BO you see how it's bringing you in and
you pay attention you're going to come
up pay attention I'll make this more
overt when it goes up you feel the up
energy okay but you are first coming
down do you see that so I make your down
energy hit the up energy and that's what
happens okay
just
okay
try all right you have to understand the
training
energetically if you look at
iido as a martial
art ITS Tactical viability comes from
its energetic consistency with what we
could could today call DST Alchemy
okay but if you go beyond its martial
viability and you're looking at what was
DST Alchemy
after the throw is not
it the throw is
more a symptom of the right d
Alchemy
so why is this a DST alchemical
practice because the Y as aspect
generated per prescription by
UK is an aspect in the cosmos that is
constantly working its way through your
own
humanness and the alchemical formula
you're
after for the
purposes of the
spiritual reconciliation you after use
is jiu-jitsu's non-c
contestation energetically and
spiritually so when he pushes at the
Young aspect what I'm going to do is
non-contest
internally so I keep releasing releasing
releasing
releasing releasing more and more more
but not being
moved more and and
more now at this same
moment
physically I'm touching his center
now but you you'll notice that when you
can do it that you do have the two mind
reconciliation you're calmed fear has
been
reconciled
okay
so I would say I would encourage you not
to do the throws but
really I imagine at one point I'll stop
doing the Marshall part and just do this
paired alchemical part where he'll push
and I will continue to not be triggered
by it regardless of my
posture just keep
releasing you can you can you keep ping
okay and put myself in totally
biomechanically unsound positions to see
if I can continue to
release and let that energy through
me
right again we're I'm in his Center
because of the way this
works you understand I mention this so
you stop chasing the
throat and
Chase young aspect
comes
non-contest then you'll feel the two
minds
reconcile okay we're just kind of
tasking
ourselves with or better said we have
throws where the manner in which the
throw occurs is the metric for the
energetic reconciliation do you
understand it's kind of like um an x-ray
you get to see inside what's happening
okay so we have the other one and let's
take the hand of the first and second
technique so this hand is internally
yielding externally yielding until it
gets to the second techniques out Outer
I adhesion so again it's not his grip
that I'm
doing the pressure that he gave me and
now it's now stuck on me and as I move
my hand it moves
him we're going to use that hand I'm
going this
way please note I'm not over here going
like that I'm on the I'm completely on
the
outside I don't know if the camera can
see
that not on that side of him yeah but
I'm not just touching him did you feel
it go off okay so his hand is there and
I do the same
thing here we are and then I can move
this this hand is going to
do the very first
hand but it's going to be done different
because his body is not going to stay
there so I come in this
way
I do the same
thing this is two
adhesions okay
Outside
[Music]
Inside
so same thing if he uh you can let go
okay so I'm going to come here this is
what I'm going to
do
okay same thing
boom and I'm going to stick to him I
stick okay so same
thing
stick why I keep
sticking doesn't change cuz it's in the
grip
okay let's
try do that side
again pay attention to your right
hand you feel it starting to
push this hand
like this and then you feel it you see
and then you
push just come
around does that feel right there you
feel like it's off you see then now you
pushing on this it's on see how it stays
on as
I don't push here go this
way so don't stay off until you get on
and now you can externally push the CER
let that come into relax you see we're
we're here already pay
attention this hand stays on don't go
off
five
you feel the
P yeah
right
okay hey pull is the wrong word though
yes it okay wait you're going this way
okay so just like all the ones up to
this
point it when I come around here
I don't want to overpower
this it's his it's his Instinct so pay
attention what this hand is doing okay
so let's I'm going to reduce the
pressure did you feel it go okay this
hand is going to make him push into me
as you watch watch his body in space
draw a vertical plane through him you
see watch what this hand is doing you
see you see that well that increased the
pressure here so as I increase the
pressure here just like if he's pushing
on me it helps my
adhesion so they work together so I'm
coming around I bring pressure
onto that arm you see
that that's very much what we've been
doing okay so on the very first
technique I brought
pressure
into the Coq projection you remember Bo
boom same thing on the first teing for
today I come around and I brought him
down and that's what fed Boom the CQ
projection you see all right so same
thing here on this last one it's not an
elbow
lock and then I
just try to break his arm
what is going to happen is I'll bring
energy onto that part and that part C
you projects up do you understand so I
bring him onto that
boom my he hits that
hand not me going
here
I make them hit the
half you guys see that so again here
this is just joint
manipulation instead I load his
energy onto that CQ point this time he
goes up and out okay let's try
it
now bring your mind to your gripped hand
and notice what it's doing in
[Music]
space do you feel like going up
okay
here then you go here and then we lift
that
hand on the other
side go
here pull and then you lift that I can't
even do that on that bad
shoulder so let's look at the angle we
use my bad shoulder you see here like
that
what all I'm doing now is loading that
hand there's no way do you understand
okay watch the difference that this hand
is going to
make
boom so you're
here at the bottom look at that angle I
need to load that hand let's start over
I need to load that hand with you at the
bottom bottom so you need to
be
there do you notice what I'm talking
about you're two two
angle I need
you let go I need you here when my hand
is there you're back there when your
hand is there okay now over
here
different okay now I want you to pay
attention Okay pay attention to
you what do you feel what do you do what
are you doing pay attention are
you are
you yeah are
you very I'll show
you here's
you you see that so what did you notice
that I did to keep the same
principle what do you
notice
no anyone
noce what is it your hand is going
further in under to hit the angle that
you previously described so let's watch
that UK
notra he's going to push you see he's
still coming okay I try to go forward
and him will crash you see
so don't push
you see just kind of hang out there and
I go forward to do it so that's what I
had to do on you so come back
over but either way it shows the point
that when you when I pop you you have to
be over it not here not that angle okay
I bring you
B
[Music]
pay attention to where my hand is if you
can
okay it never even came up
Okay C is
not it's not my external thing okay it's
that the energy that I let
in I now let back out of
me so energy that is coming into me I
don't care energy that's coming into me
you see the energ think about it as like
a um a leaky vessel it passed through me
you see it's going to hit the ground the
ground is not as leaky as I can be so it
hits the ground and I let it pass back
out out of me you see that do you
understand it's the same thing so if you
want you could call when it comes in and
goes through me a kind of young aspect
when it goes through me it comes back
out you see it's like a y aspect of it
came in went back out in other words un
permeable which is what I want okay so
on the technique
boom it's that I let that energy come
back into that part he's basing
on not that I go I can't even lift that
on Boom is where I hit bounce it
back just like here
[Music]
okay let's try try not to throw see you
can just pop he let's take away the
temptation of the throat okay